das mit der Verbindung zu den
ukrainischen Streitkräften ist natürlich
Kreml Propaganda pur freien fragen wir
nach bei Henna Hebestreit in Odessa wie
die Situation dort ist Herr beschreibt
wie sieht es denn bei ihnen am Schwarzen
Meer mit der Stromversorgung in der
Region Odessa aus
und man das Wortspiel zu bemühen guten
Abend erstmal das Wortspiel zu bemühen
es sieht sehr schwarz aus 70% der
Stromkunden in und um und deshalb sind
vom Netz getrennt worden und deswegen
sehr davon ab wer noch alles in dem Netz
mit dran ist ob man getrennt wird oder
nicht wenn man z.B am gleichen Kabel
hängt wie eine Polizeistation hat man
Glück bekommt den Strom wenn man
irgendwie an einer Pommesbude hängt die
gerade nicht wichtig ist dann hat sowohl
die Pommesbude also der Wohnblock
dahinter eben kein Strom trotzdem gehen
die Leute hier sehr kreativ damit um vor
den Restaurants stehen zum Beispiel
Generatoren damit wenigstens die Leute
was zu essen kriegen viele können ja
auch zu Hause nicht kochen wenn der
Strom nicht da ist also die Leute
versuchen sich damit vielleicht zu
arrangieren wir haben in den Bericht
gerade gesehen in Kiel hattest bereits
geschneit auch in anderen Regionen gibt
es bereits minus gerade zu vermelden das
ist ja eine ganz gezielte Strategie der
Russen auf einmal die Bevölkerung zu
machen wie geht denn das Land damit um
ja auch da sind die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer sehr kreativ es ist so so wie
wieder Strom da ist und das ist nicht so
oft am Tag der Fall gerade auch rund um
Kiew nicht gehen die Leute sehr schnell
an ihre Waschmaschine und gucken ob Sie
Ihre Wäsche links noch fertig kriegen
solange der Strom da ist das gleiche ist
mit mit vorkochen zum Beispiel Akkus
aufladen für den für das Handy und all
solche Sachen das ist alles sehr
relevant und das muss alles ein sehr
kurzer Zeit passieren wir haben auch mit
einer einer Lehrerin gesprochen und
einer einer Mutter die wir vor einigen
Monaten für das Ausland schon einmal
porträtiert haben wir wollten wissen wie
die denn damit umgehen und da hieß es ja
in der Schule ist das alles super die
jede Schule hat ein Notstromaggregat
solange das Kind in der Schule ist alles
fein zu Hause aber kein Strom kein
Computer funktioniert das ist also alles
schon eine Situation wo man sich
überlegt hier mitten in Europa hat man
keinen Strom man ist den bösen Nachbarn
nicht gefällt das sind schon
Verhältnisse also das ist ein Ding es
gab ja im Laufe dieser Woche wieder ganz
heftige Angriffe der Russen mit
Artillerie und Raketen ich Schraube am
Dienstag sind fast 100 Raketen
abgeschossen worden gott lob sind glaube
ich 70 abgefangen worden von der
ukrainischen Luftabwehr daraufhin wurde
ja hier im Westen immer wieder darüber
spekuliert ob es jetzt nicht die
Situation wäre wo der Winter von der Tür
steht wo man eventuell versuchen sollte
Gespräche zu finden mit Russland also
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland was
sagen denn die Leute wollen die Menschen
weiter durchhalten diese Linie von
selensky dass das ganze Land
zurückerobert wird oder gibt es da jetzt
vielleicht auch Diskussionen das
vielleicht Verhandlungen sinnvoll werden
damit wären damit das Sterben ein Ende
hat
von diesen Diskussionen so ist sie denn
gibt haben wir zumindest nichts
mitbekommen wir sind seit gestern seit
vorgestern hier in der Gegend
runddruckressen unterwegs gewesen wo die
Leute hier wirklich bis vor einer Woche
massive Probleme mit den russischen
Besatzern hatten selbst da heißt es nö
auf gar keinen Fall Verhandlungen
solange die Russen noch im Land sind und
es gab sogar Leute die sagt man soll bis
an die Grenzen in von 1991 Zurückgehen
der Beginn der modernen Ukraine in dem
Sinne wenn man das so will nein es gibt
überhaupt niemanden der hier sich
öffentlich von der Fernsehkamera dazu
bekennt und sagt nein also wir wollen
das jetzt durchziehen wir wollen der
Sache ein ein Ende machen Russland muss
raus und manche sagen auch mit dem
russischen Präsidenten Putin sei
überhaupt nicht zu verhandeln dem traut
hier kein Mensch mehr über den Weg also
die Ukraine ist entschlossen
durchzuhalten der Hebestreit zum Schluss
schließt sich für mich vor allem auch
jetzt in der Weihnachtszeit die Frage an
was können wir denn tun um die Ukraine
jetzt besonders zu unterstützen was
braucht denn das Land ja außer
vielleicht moralische Unterstützung
wenn man mal auf die politische Ebene
gehen dann kommt die alte Forderung sie
brauchen Panzer sie brauchen Waffen sie
brauchen Munition für die Luftabwehr die
Kanonen die zum Teil aus dem Westen
geliefert worden sind müssen repariert
werden das ist das eine das zweite sind
natürlich die vielen privaten Spenden an
Organisationen wo man sagen kann okay
die wissen was in dieser Situation
gebraucht wird andecken an an allen
Dingen die für Wärme sorgen ohne dass
man da auf Strom angewiesen ist es gibt
aber auch eine ganz anderen Aspekt das
hat mir unsere ukrainische Mitarbeiterin
erzählt viele haben ihre Kinder ins
Ausland gebracht und sind inzwischen
wieder zurück die Kinder sind aber noch
z.B auch in Deutschland und die kriegen
riesen Probleme damit wenn Sie
minderjährig sind und haben keinen
Vormund das heißt ähm da ist ein ein
großer Bedarf da dass ich Leute dieser
Minderjährigen annehmen und sagen okay
wir passen auf die auch in dem Sinne
dass die sich ähm wofür man eben
erwachsene brauchen eine Unterschrift
für irgendwas bekommen kann und
dergleichen mehr weil ohne ihre Eltern
sind die langfristig in Deutschland und
auch in anderen europäischen Staaten
wirklich hilflos und das ist schon
Besuch der Schule in Riesenproblem was
macht man zum Beispiel wenn es ein
Ausflug geben soll und so also das sind
das sind auch der ganz humanitären Ebene
Sachen wo man in Deutschland auch helfen
kann man muss sich einfach nur an die
Schule wenden oder an Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer die da Kontakt haben in diese
Bereiche rein das ist ein sehr wichtiger
Aspekt Streit war das aus Odessa ich
sage danke für Ihre Zeit und danke für
diese Erläuterungen